welcome back to CBS mornings this is a
wild story this week 48 Hours
investigates a high-stakes robbery of a
California Bank back in November 2000
three masked gunmen broke into the home
of bank manager Michelle Renee they held
her and her seven-year-old daughter
hostage well the next morning the men
said they had strapped Dynamite to the
pair and they forced Renee to rob her
own bank 48 Hours contributor Tracy
Smith has the story
the years haven't erased Michelle
Renee's memory if you close your eyes
can you still see it all of it I can
still see all of it it was November 21st
2000 when three men broke down the door
I was screaming no no no where's Bria
she was face down with a gun to her head
and I heard her say are you going to
kill my mommy are you going to kill me
morning the kidnapper strapped them with
dynamite they said you're gonna rob the
bank for us or you will disintegrate
your daughter will go first
the gunman put Bria in a closet while
Michelle drove to work the ringleader
crouched in the back seat
be brave Mommy that was the last thing
she said before I walked out to go to
the bank did you feel Brave no just
before nine o'clock Michelle walked out
of the bank with 360 thousand dollars
once the gunman took off with the money
she raced home not sure what she'd find
when she got there oh my gosh she was
alive I did it we did it the gunman had
left the dynamite on Michelle's back
which the bomb squad discovered was fake
during the hostage ordeal Michelle had
recognized the ringleader's eyes
he'd posed as a customer at the bank and
left his card my brain was going oh my
gosh don't let him know that you know
the lead would help Crack the Case
but when investigators made arrests
another suspect lied and said Michelle
had been in on it
in court defense attorney herb Weston
put Michelle on the defensive what was
your strategy going into trial my
strategy was to beat the hell out of the
victim
I was treated like I was the criminal
Tracy Smith joins us now at the table
why why were this mother and daughter
targeted well the bank branch where
Michelle was a manager was close to the
suspect's house they'd apparently been
watching them for a while and they
decided she was an easy target single
mom with a young daughter and how were
investigators able to arrest the
suspects well Michelle recognized the
ringleader's eyes through his mask and
he'd left a card at her bank in her desk
she had the card and get this his real
name was on the card
so that launched the investigation and
led to the other suspects it's always
that one little thing that you think you
can't leave that fingerprint type of
thing right right but here's the twist
in trial this guy who seems pretty dumb
gets pretty smart oh interesting okay
and you have to watch to find out what
that little twist is Tracy thank you
good to see you thanks nice to have you
in New York you can see Tracy's report
the kidnapping of Michelle and Brio
Renee on 48 hours tomorrow night 10 9
Central right here on CBS and of course
on our streaming service Paramount Plus